en cette fin show 2015 l'équipe se
tourne les pouces au centre de
traitement ebola de médecins sans
frontières à conakry la capitale de la
guinée voilà c'était très calme j'étais
ici entre septembre et fin janvier et
s'était plaint en avait entre 50 et 80
patients on va aujourd'hui on en a zéro
soudain un appel interrompt notre
conversation
oui dix mois un cas confirmé - et on
sait que c'est un enfant qui a été qui
présentent des symptômes
quelques heures plus tard la nouvelle
est transmise ici c'est le centre
nerveux des essais vaccinaux de l'om est
l'organisation mondiale de la santé nih
une nouvelle victime des mollahs vient
s'ajouter au tableau et s'était
confirmée ce contenu
pour doit vite retrouver qui a été en
contact avec l'enfant en cette fin
d'épidémie
c'est l'une des dernières chances pour
tester l'efficacité d'un vaccin canadien
contre ebola un vaccin pourtant
découvert il y a dix ans quand ça tombe
par douzaines à tout les jours et que
chaque fois tu fais ce que tu peux leur
malheur être vingt sept est déshydratée
mais qu'au bout de la ligne
le constat est le dénouement du sort va
être la même
c'est ce qui est difficile et ça se
répète et ça se répète et ça se répète
pour affronter l'épidémie d'ebola la
plus meurtrière de l'histoire
les soignants n'ont pu compter sur aucun
vaccin ni traitement
ils ont vu mourir des milliers de leurs
patients et des centaines de leurs
collègues which would have nous aurions
dû y voir un vaccin avant 2014
il était dans le congélateur on comprend
tout ce que l'industrie enfin c'est pas
des philanthropes c'est bien clair
donc l'industrie ne peut produire des
quelque chose que s'il y a un marché
c'est la base de l'économie
en ce début d'été après des mois de
crise
les guinéens tente de reprendre une vie
normale et de relancer une économie qui
s'est effondré à cause de l'épidémie
mais partout des affiches rappellent
qu'il est trop tôt pour baisser la garde
pour laisser tomber les mesures de
précaution comme le lavage des mains et
la prise de température avant d'entrer
dans les édifices publics
nous assistons ce matin-là à la réunion
du comité de coordination nationale de
lutte contre et bola hélas lieu trois
fois par semaine aucun cas ne doit lui
échapper sinon c'est une nouvelle chaîne
de transmission qui va démarrer s'était
jamais
les dernières informations comme je le
disais ils sont été retrouvé on espère
que des actions tous les partenaires
internationaux sont là les américains
des centers for disease control médecins
sans frontières l'organisation mondiale
de la santé les français et même des
représentants de l' agence de santé
publique canadienne des partenaires à
qui les guinéennes doivent parfois
rappeler la dure réalité de leur pays
cette concertation internationale offre
tout un contraste avec la situation qui
prévalait quinze mois plus tôt alors que
personne ne soupçonnait ou ne voulait
voir l'ampleur de la crise qui se
préparait sur demande écrite à des
années de retard et dans le procès d'une
info reconnaître que cette maladie quand
même à tromper la plupart
les gens qui avaient en charge de gérer
passé on pensait que c'était une
épidémie qui n'allaient pas très dur
c'est en mars 2014
haggui qui dit que les premiers cas
d'ebola sont formellement identifié
c'est la souche zaïre la plus mortelle
le virus n'avait jamais frappé en guinée
quand les équipes d'urgence de loin des
médecins sans frontières arrivent sur
place
elle s'aperçoit vite que cette épidémie
est inhabituelle vu qu'à ce moment-là y
avait des cas à plus de 250 km de
distance
on se dit c'est vraiment un épidémique
est différente qui est géographiquement
très très très éparpillé
mais non je ne vous inquiétez pas ce
qu'on savait que c'était quand même
possiblement une bombe à retardement au
cours des deux mois qui suivront
personne n'écoutera les messages
alarmants de médecins sans frontières ni
le gouvernement guinéen
ni l'organisation mondiale de la santé
en partie pour ne pas créer de panique
et nuire à l'économie du pays
la maladie en profite pour se propager
dans la capitale conakry et dans les
pays voisins
la sierra leone et le liberia c'est qui
la première personne dans votre famille
qui a été atteinte de la maladie et
comment c'est arrivé
la première personne où tu sais que
c'est manqué quelle a été la première
malade
les deux jours après ma grande c'est
aussi hélas jcd ne sais pas comment
vivez vous
oumar touré et son frère ces coûts sont
des survivants d'ebola ils ont perdu six
membres de leur famille durant
l'épidémie
ils ont tous deux passé trois semaines
dans un centre de traitement anti bola
le frère aîné est mort dans les bras
d'oumar mais d'une fois pour l'idole
d'imagés élevé jette
il ne boit pas il était dernièrement
invitation de vente et de samedi ils
voulaient descendre à terre je me suis
retourné j'ai entendu mais les médecins
d'avant je l'appelais dvd mais d'époque
mois il peut se retourner mon frère aîné
est aussi rapide et sain et trembler
jusqu'à une arène dinannais tous les
jours de 14h au début de l'épidémie dans
les pays touchés
les autorités ont martelé le même
message ebola est un virus mortel pour
lequel il n'existe aucun remède
résultat une partie de la population a
refusé d'aller dans les centres de
traitement parfois violemment
ce qui a contribué à propager l'épidémie
allez dire à quelqu'un que il maladies
qui tuent a plus de 50 pour ça y'a pas
de traitement il faut que vous fassiez
soignés dans un centre avec des
cosmonautes loin de votre famille puis
j'ai un problème en mourir tout seul je
suis désolé c'est pas sexy ça marche pas
puis c'est pas vendeur
des travailleurs de la santé ont même
été attaqué à l'époque toutes sortes de
rumeurs attise la méfiance de la
population visée 17e avec certains des
maisons qui n'ont pas circulé ici
aubenas existe et c'était une pointe etc
etc on dit même rien pour non seulement
conduire la business pc de la business
quoi ces deux là ma compréhension
ces deux-là mal compris ainsi certains
détracteurs ont alimenté que celle des
européens qui ont introduit cette
maladie en guinée et qui valent même les
organes déjà repris sont victimes
d'autres esprits malins aussi ont
diffusé que c'est le virus qui au
contenu était saine aux agents qui
divise le virus contre la population
c'était malade et inventer et et des
préjugés
suite à la déclaration du fait qu'on a
dit qu'il ya pas de médicaments et de
vaccins était en fait un parent de loi
que les gens n'ont pas adopté nos
comportements qu'on souhaite r pour le
contrôle rappel de ce type
et ce n'est pas seulement la population
qui a peur et qu'ils se méfient il
devient de plus en plus difficile de
recruter des soignants nous sommes les
victimes directes
je n'ai pas mis pied dans un centre
sanitaire
si j'avais peur nous coller qui dirait
que son parti sont bons oui je voulais
qu'ils sont morts qui sont pas des
médecins qui sont partis qui sont
décédés
au début c'était d'ici là yanez qui
visaient même si on met 10 des millions
et je vais pas finir beaucoup suffisait
de venir travailler demain où il y avait
pas assez de moyens
nous on a commencé je pense on était
douze comme ça on est discutable comme
ça mais des fois on moi par exemple
projet recruter quelqu'un je lui ai
fermé le lendemain m'appellait qui n'y
va pas trouver ici n'était pas là ne
veulent pas que l'unmis la peur les
fragiles systèmes de santé des pays
touchés ne sont pas de taille pour faire
face à la maladie
les infirmiers les médecins manquent de
tout de matériel de protection comme de
formation le virus les dessine dans les
centres de msf où les troupes sont
épuisés et débordés
un nombre sans précédent de travailleurs
sera aussi infectés en trois mois
le virus se propage sur plus de 60 sites
différents médecins sans frontières
déclare que l'épidémie est maintenant
hors de contrôle
ça nous prenait des outils différents on
rêvait d'un traitement c'est sûr parce
que c'était tellement mais tellement
difficile apporter des soins aux
patients
et l'autre chose aussi c'est considérer
son avait un outil pour faire la
prévention des maladies ce serait ça
serait merveilleux
d'autres voix réclament la même chose le
britannique jennifer dirige le wellcome
trust le deuxième fonds philanthropique
en importance au monde dans le domaine
de la santé
je me souviens d'avoir écrit à ce sujet
en juin demandant des études sur des
traitements et des vaccins à ce moment
là il y avait environ 200 morts vers la
fin de l'année
on se dirigeait vers plus de dix mille
morts le 8 ou 2014
près de 1000 morts plus tard la
directrice générale de l oms déclare
enfin que l'épidémie d'ebola constitue
une urgence mondiale et que la
communauté internationale doit se
mobiliser
du même coup on donne le feu vert à
l'utilisation de traitements
expérimentaux sur le terrain le problème
c'est qu'il n'ya rien de bien avancé
dans le pipeline pharmaceutique
tous ces vaccins ces médicaments qui
était encore un stade très très
préliminaires puisqu'en fait rien
n'avait encore été testé chez l'homme on
s'est dit c'est moi aussi il faut il
faut il faut y aller et ceci a été
vraiment le début de l'engagement de
l'om est pour la recherche
une équipe internationale de médecins
arrivent iam beaucoup au zaïre
aujourd'hui la république démocratique
du congo une maladie mystérieuse sèment
la terreur dans ce village reculé où
oeuvre une mission catholique
le docteur peter piotte et ses collègues
découvrent un virus jusque là inconnu il
le baptise ebola du nom de la rivière
qui coule dans la région en guerre
depuis il y a eu 23 autres flambée
d'ebola en afrique qui ont touché
quelques dizaines ou centaines de
personnes à chaque fois
le virus est cantonné dans des régions
isolées
ils n'attirent pas beaucoup l'attention
encore moins celle du monde de la
recherche pharmaceutique
mais les attentats du 11 septembre 2001
vont changer la donne
une semaine après les attaques
une série d' enveloppes piégées à
l'entracte le bacille du charbon fait
cinq morts aux etats unis les autorités
s'inquiètent de tous les agents
dangereux qui pourraient être utilisés
par des terroristes
ebola se retrouvent sur la liste le
canada mais surtout les états unis
débloque des budgets de biodéfense pour
la recherche de traitements et de
vaccins le canada verse 7 millions de
dollars au fil des ans pour la recherche
autour du virus ebola
ça faisait partie des priorités dans le
domaine de la recherche de solutions
biologiques à des menaces biologiques
c'est un département défense nationale
du canada qui a subventionné les
supporter que rural et premier au vaccin
vsv au traitement aussi
le docteur gary copine guerre est un
conférencier recherché
il est chef des agents pathogènes au
laboratoire national de microbiologie de
winnipeg
c'est le seul laboratoire de niveau iv
au pays
on y travaille sur les organismes
infectieux les plus dangereux de la
planète
il arrive au laboratoire en 2005 où on
fait déjà des recherches sur le vaccin
plusieurs voyages sur le terrain lui
permettront de constater les ravages
causés par la maladie
pour nous les scientifiques ce qui est
important c'est de développer un vaccin
puis pour nous l'intérêt vraiment majeur
c'était d'aider les populations qui
souffrent dans l'émergence de se dire ça
en 2005 le laboratoire de winnipeg
annonce avec fierté que vaccins contre
ebola est efficace dans des essais sur
des primates fauche l'espoir et ce sera
at il dit les chercheurs veulent
maintenant le tester sur les humains et
le faire approuver le plus tôt possible
de france débute alors la recherche pour
trouver une compagnie qui sera faire
franchir au vaccin toutes ces étapes
pour arriver sur le marché en fait avait
personne avec l'expérience à l'époque
sur comment on emmène un produit
vraiment du laboratoire à la clinique
je pense qu'il ya un optimisme très
grande et chercheurs qui se disent c'est
tellement bon on veut tellement on y
croit tellement aussi mais la tâche
s'avère plus difficile que prévu
la licence du vaccin n'intéresse
personne il faudra cinq ans pour trouver
un partenaire commercial et l' agence de
la santé publique dont relève le
laboratoire doit se tourner vers les
états unis
normalement j'ai senti que l'intérêt des
offres qu'il faut qu'ils soient mises
public
puis tout le monde peut en faire une
offre pour 0 qui nous mèneront à ces
cinq ans nos projets on veut faire 6
puis est ce qu'on peut avoir la licence
à l'époque avait tellement un peu
d'intérêt en fait que la façon dont ça
c'est fait s'est il y avait un chercheur
qui travaillaient avec un avec la lave
qui participaient aux états unis pour
travailler un clan pour cette compagnie
yoolink puis qui a commencé à la
deuxième essai vaccinal c'est vraiment
super yoolink génétique est une petite
compagnie de biotechnologie basée en
iowa en 2010 sa filiale bayo protection
systems verse deux cent cinq mille
dollars au canada pour la licence de son
vaccin une infection 2 septembre 2014
médecins sans frontières lance un nouvel
appel à l'aide désespéré devant l'onu
des moyens concrets se font attendre sur
le terrain
la pression s'accentue sur
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
elle convoque 200 experts à genève
dirigeants chercheurs philanthrope et
représentants de l'industrie
pharmaceutique pour tenter de freiner
l'épidémie on décide d'accélérer un
processus qui normalement prend des
années
wilsey diop nous étions prêts à financer
les meilleures idées allaient faire
avancer rapidement agir en quelques
heures ou quelques jours afin que
l'argent soit disponible pour les
candidats les plus prometteurs 8
traitements expérimentaux sont
identifiés deux vaccins sont retenus
dont le vsv est bof canadiens notamment
parce qu'il existe déjà 1500 fioles la
docteure marie paule kieny espère que
les vaccins pourront être disponibles
dès novembre 2014 pour ceux qui sont les
plus exposés les travailleurs de la
santé
we have band peut porter la combinaison
que pour cent vingt minutes et il y à
tous ces patients il fallait presser la
bouteille de patients pendant qu'on
examinait le patient d'à côté et les
bouteilles qu'on ait un tas d'aiguilhe
j'ai retiré les aiguilles pour ne pas me
piquer steve mason
j'ai vu les jeter dans le contenant
désigné mais ils étaient tous pleins
faits et j'ai poussé l'aiguillât
l'intérieur et elle m'est rentré dans le
pouce l'accident survient à la fin du
mois de septembre 2014 à l'hôpital de
kenema en sierra leone le docteur luis
robinson un médecin américain s'est
porté volontaire pour le compte de l'
oms les conditions sont particulièrement
chaotique
ma première réaction a été je ne le dis
à personne je ne voulais pas penser à ça
mais j'ai senti que mon pouce saignait
et je me suis dit il faut vraiment que
je m'en occupe
des hôtesses moins de 48 heures plus
tard il est à bord d'un avion privé
affrété spécialement pour lui
en route pour les états unis les
autorités américaines de la santé lui
offre la panoplie des traitements et
vaccins expérimentaux disponibles il
choisit le vaccin canadien se noie
galant dès que je suis monté à bord de
l'avion
j'ai signé le consentement et ils me
l'ont injectée dans le bras pendant le
décollage
j'ai eu la chance d'être évacués quand
les autres devenaient malades les locaux
on les mettait dans le centre de
traitement ebola c'est pour ça que
plusieurs sont morts ces gens là il
travaillait depuis des mois et j'ai été
seulement là trois semaines je me suis
sentie coupable par rapport à ça
finalement les tests révéleront que le
docteur robinson n'avait jamais
contracté le virus ebola
parce que j'ai eu la chance de naître en
amérique j'ai eu accès à certaines
choses mais si vous êtes née en sierra
leone votre vie ne vaut pas autant
quarante membres du personnel sont morts
durant l'épidémie à l'hôpital de kenema
la plupart des travailleurs
internationaux qui ont été infectées ont
été évacués ils ont souvent eu accès aux
rares médicaments expérimentaux dès le
début la majorité de leurs collègues
ouest africains eux devront attendre le
début des essais cliniques pour les
recevoir
8 octobre 2014 le libérien thompson
qu'une meurt dans un hôpital de dallas
au texas
la première victime des mollahs à
décéder en sol américain
puis deux infirmières qui l'ont traité
sont infectés à leur tour les états unis
sont pris d'une panique contagieuse le
fieu bola comme le baptise alors ebola
peut traverser l'océan
les travailleurs de la santé qui s'était
porté volontaire en afrique de l'ouest
sont traqués par les autorités et les
médias et mis en quarantaine
même s'ils ne présentent aucun symptôme
la crainte d'une épidémie planétaire
créer une fièvre boursière les biotech
qui travaillent sur un vaccin ou un
traitement son propulsé à l'avant-scène
et voient leurs titres s'envoler à la
même période la compagnie new link
conclu un accord de licence mondial avec
le géant pharmaceutique merck pour le
vaccin vsv est bonne elle empoche le
gros lot 50 millions de dollars pour une
licence payée 205000
bwin amine est un analyste en
biotechnologie pour la firme
d'investissement jeffries à new york
new line genetics est l'une des
compagnies qui suit près byford ya peu
d'air mais avant l'épidémie
que saviez vous à propos de ce vaccin se
concentre surtout sur le développement
de traitements contre le cancer
on n'a pas beaucoup parlé de ses
programmes sur les maladies infectieuses
comme le vaccin contre ebola les petites
bio tech comme yoolink fonctionne à
perte pendant des années en attendant le
produit qui leur permettra de faire une
percée sur le marché
les actionnaires de la compagnie fonde
beaucoup d'espoirs actuellement sur un
traitement pour le cancer pancréatique
il pourrait rapporter jusqu'à un
milliard de dollars selon bwin amin
le vaccin contre ebola n'était pas la
première priorité ce sera difficile pour
eux cela prendrait beaucoup de
ressources et ça les empêcherait de
concentrer leurs efforts sur les
médicaments contre le cancer dans le
monde de la biotechnologie les
médicaments ont besoin d'un marché les
investisseurs recherchent des marchés
intéressants
un vaccin contre ebola
ce n'est pas quelque chose que l'on peut
quantifier facilement c'est quelque
chose qu'ils éviteraient selon moi je ne
veux pas les critiquer vraiment pas mais
dans ce monde
les seuls qui ont la capacité de
développer des vaccins sont les grandes
sociétés pharmaceutiques mais ce ne sont
pas les biotech et ce matin
le docteur adèle mahmoud est un
spécialiste des maladies infectieuses
il a dirigé l'unité des vaccins chez
marc de 1998 à 2006 selon lui seules
quelques grandes pharmaceutiques ont les
infrastructures les équipes et l'argent
nécessaire pour développer un vaccin
jusqu'au bout mais elles veulent des
profits de lagence la santé publique dit
qu'elle a contacté les grandes
compagnies pharmaceutiques et qu'elles
ont toutes dit non 9,6 des quelques les
échanges même si les calculs on démontre
qu'il n'y a pas de marché potentiel pour
récupérer vos dépenses de développement
vaccine pour développer un vaccin de
cette découverte à son déploiement sur
le marché ça coûte en moyenne 1 milliard
de dollars à béléné reste bas vont nous
link kewego kuan yew link a acquis la
licence de l' agence de la santé
publique
j'imagine qu'il savait qu'il existait
des fonds des fonds dans lesquels il
pouvait puiser les subventions du
gouvernement au cours des ans
yoolink a reçu plus de 7 millions de
dollars en subventions de la défense
américaine mais pour un ensemble de
maladies infectieuses dans les
communiqués et les rapports financiers
aucune mention de travaux spécifiques
sur le vsv est bof
nous avons réussi à retrouver l'ancien
chercheur de winnipeg qui est allé
travailler chez new line qu il affirme
n'avoir vu aucun travail sur le vaccin
dans le laboratoire de la compagnie
ramon flic a été chef des vaccins de
biodéfense chez new line jusqu'en 2013
quand le canada a vendu la licence du
vaccin contre ebola le contrat stipulait
que la compagnie devait faire les
efforts commercialement raisonnable pour
l'amener sur le marché parce qu'on
pensait vraiment cette compagnie là à
les amener le vaccin sur le marché nous
avions absolument toutes les certitudes
à ce moment à l'autre qu'elle était
capable de faire son mandat
c'est une compagnie que des montres et
des expertises que démontrer les
savoir-faire qui a démontré qu'elle
avait en main un plan d'affaires et les
et les étapes nécessaires à aller de
l'avant
c'est sûr que pour une agence
gouvernementale comme l' agence de la
santé publique du canada
on ne s'aventure pas à faire des essais
cliniques on ne s'aventure pas à mettre
en marché des produits d'une façon
générale en 2010 l' agence de la santé
publique fait fabriquer un lot de 1500
fioles pour les dernières études
précliniques sur les animaux c'est
encore le canada qui paye 877 1000 $ en
principe new line qui devait prendre la
relève pour commencer les tests
cliniques sur les humains
une fois qu'on a un lot clinique la
développement clinique de départ qu'on
appelle la face c'est pas des gros
montants d'argent de 150 nairas pour
faire une étude clinique de phase 1 le
premier premier niveau pour regarder si
c'est vraiment sécuritaire
peut-être une dose 2
moins de 50 personnes est ce que vous
savez c'est la compagnie se prépare est
ce qu on peut mentionner d'une façon
directe c'est que dans la dans la phase
d'accord avec la compagnie a souhaité
une encore qui est assez formel la
compagnie doit déposer un plan
d'affaires parce qu'on savait quand ça
allait commencer les essais de phase 1
j'ai passé de la relation avec moi
lagence a refusé de nous dire quel était
ce plan d'affaires nous ne savons pas
quel suivi a été fait auprès de la
compagnie toutes nos demandes d'accès à
l'information auprès de l'agent ce sont
demeurées sans réponse new line genetics
n'a pas voulu nous accorder d'entrevues
dans un long courriel
elle affirme avoir fait un travail
considérable sur le vaccin en
collaboration avec l' agence de la santé
publique
elle dit qu'elle avait entamé des
démarches auprès du gouvernement
américain et qu'elle était presque prête
à faire des essais cliniques
lorsque l'épidémie survenue mais selon
l'ex employé ramon flics
la compagnie avait surtout un rôle
secondaire et peinait à obtenir des
subventions
au moment où la crise éclate
aucun essai n'a commencé sur les humains
et on perd de précieux mois
le bilan s'alourdit
l' oms ne parvient pas comme prévu à
offrir dès novembre 2014
le vaccin aux travailleurs de la santé
est déjà en décembre
la courbe d'infection en afrique de
l'ouest commence à diminuer les
autorités vont bientôt se demander s'il
y aura assez de cas pour aller jusqu'au
bout des essais cliniques
juin 2015
en route vers capellen plateau une
communauté à deux heures environ de la
capitale conakry
nous accompagnons une équipe de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
un enfant est décédé du virus ebola
aujourd'hui les personnes qui ont été en
contact avec lui vont recevoir le vaccin
canadien
moi j'ai été la première personne
c'est la base
de classer le dance 3 masc
cela fait trois mois maintenant que la
dernière phase des essais pour tester
l'efficacité du vaccin a finalement
commencé en guinée chez les travailleurs
de la santé et dans les populations
touchées mais c'est une course contre la
montre
il n'y a plus qu'une poignée de cas par
semaine est-ce que ça à cause des
inquiétudes le fait que le nombre de
crédits
on espère que
avec ses dents thomas d
oui mais ça devait les aider vos
faire une commune à part pour le monde
entier attend le résultat
à notre arrivée le personnel de l'om s
est déjà installée depuis plusieurs
heures les volontaires sont nombreux et
les essais vont bon train et pas
toujours comme ça quand vous allez dans
les communautés non c'est pas toujours
comme ça parce qu'il ya toujours des
résistances temps ont vacciné a comme ça
il ya yves magat l'agression on ne l'a
pas de la population ils avaient cassé
deux villes au moins 5 du prg la
population reste méfiante face à tous
ceux qui sont associés à imola
les équipes de vaccination doit faire
preuve de doigté et bien préparer le
terrain pour des raisons de sécurité on
s'est installé dans la cour du chef de
quartier
oui sinon c'est tout
c'est pour donner l'exemple à la
population ils sont venus d'abord
expliqué l'explication que nous aussi on
a sensibilisé on a dit que ces scènes
essaye ati nation ou ne pas s'y sont
bien compliqué pour la science certains
groupes sont vaccinés immédiatement
après l'apparition de nouveaux cas
d'autres comme celui ci 21 jours plus
tard soit la période nécessaire à la
maladie pour se développer
le but comparer le nombre d'apparitions
de nouveaux cas dans les deux groupes
c'est cette chanson si j'avais fait ça
va sans rien parce que ça va donner la
santé à la population une maladie qu'on
allait faire le nom de la salle maladie
l'a donc faut continuer mais encore des
cas c'est pas terminé et je pense que la
méthodologie qu'on a choisis pour le
faire 20 marché et va nous permettre de
voir si ce vaccin est efficace ou pas
comme le gros de l'épidémie est déjà
passé l'espoir maintenant est d'avoir au
bout un outil pour la prochaine fois car
déjà la récolte ms du côté des autres
vaccins et traitements testés pendant
l'épidémie soit faute de cas comme au
libéria ou parce qu'il s'avère
inefficace
we believe the world is zone de bugs au
foehn efficace
c'est beau la vaccine un mois après
notre passage en guinée
'l'annonce fait le tour du monde les
résultats intérimaires indique que le
vaccin canadien est efficace à 100%
parmi ceux qui ont été vaccinés
immédiatement aucun cas d'infection
tandis que seize personnes ont contracté
le virus ebola dans les groupes vaccinés
trois semaines plus tard
les essais cliniques ont été menés en
des temps record une bonne nouvelle pour
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
très critiqué pour sa réponse tardive
durant la crise mais pour joindre ue
dont l'organisme a aussi collaboré à
l'étude
c'est un succès 12 amer je dirais la
bonne chose la panique global planeta
c'est qu'à un moment donné les gens
finissent par faire quelque chose c'est
que c'est quand même extraordinaire
qu'est ce qui s'est passé parce que de
façon générale ça prend beaucoup plus de
temps que ça se le dit c'est
impardonnable parce que si on avait fait
notre boulot en amont par rapport à
cette maladie le bon on n'aurait pas
fait face à ce désastre l'eau et
peut-être qu'on aurait prévenu
on parle de onze mille décès mais
peut-être plusieurs milliers
dans la capitale guinéenne
les survivants oumar et sékou touré et
c'est tant bien que mal de rebâtir leur
vie ils ont été accueillis par une tante
ils sont retournés aux études mais ils
doivent maintenant faire face à la
stigmatisation les 1.6 ghz et voilà vos
anciens amis est ce que vous les voyez
encore evola sera toujours une maladie
de pays pauvres en afrique subsaharienne
il n'y a donc pas de marché qui va
générer des revenus suffisants
c'est avant tout un enjeu de santé
publique
il faut la collaboration de tous de la
santé publique de la philanthropie et de
l'industrie ou habitude à une fois que
la recherche fondamentale est fait il
faut la développer jusqu'au point où on
peut l'utiliser très rapidement les
différences qu'il ya des produits comme
ceux qui sont nécessaires à développer
même si c'est pas un marché commercial
en bout de ligne puis faut pouvoir les
identifier puis pour et des partenaires
pour que ses priorités locke qui sont
des priorités basé sur xg regza
compenser les phares avant c'est aussi
pour le vaccin canadien maintenant
développé par marc la partie n'est pas
encore gagnée
il n'a toujours pas été approuvé par les
autorités réglementaires comme la f10
est américaine en attendant max est
engagée à rendre disponibles trois cent
mille doses en cas d'urgence kevin dabou
fr penser que sans l'épidémie il y
aurait eu un vaccin contre ebola un jour
au sud rêve
nous aurions dû parce que c'est vaccin
prometteur il était dans le congélateur
ils ont été découverts vers la fin du
xxème début du 21e siècle il était dans
le congélateur et l'histoire du vaccin
contre ebola est loin d'être un cas
unique
d'autres médicaments prometteurs mais
pas assez lucratif reste bloqué dans ce
qu'on appelle la vallée de la mort
pharmaceutique
cette étape coûteuse entre la découverte
et la commercialisation
il ya beaucoup de produits comme ça dans
le congélateur
le strass mersch
la fièvre de lassa le marburg
chikungunya le virus nipah le virus du
nil
la liste est longue comment jouer un
petit peu les choses c'est que
honnêtement c'est probablement que la
prochaine fois l'épidémie d'une telle
ampleur à s'appelle repos ebola a va
s'appeler ou autre chose et et que
quelque part on va être encore un peu
pris par surprise
là